hello and welcome to this video playing
international master it's why I don't
know who that is
it's got I already have a bit of a
history here against him okay yeah I
tried this recently in a game
transported into the Slav exchange
let's see if this transposition is
happening again no that's interesting
that's actually what I recommended in my
head my banker repertoire Queen to c7
very much preventing the London no I
think it's decent
okay so isn't that a Ted a bit a bit
risky here from black just a little bit
there with this diagonal let's see I
could be pins that's reading Russia
there could be pins there are pins yeah
okay so first of all this I can do this
first
[Music]
hmm let's think about it I would like to
play some 95 push it be 5 so I'm
starting with this so there's no Bishop
takes f3 quickly played quickly played
mm-hmm and why not
okay Nev that was probably not a good
way to play okay so he's giving me a
pawn I can grab c5 still not so happy
about all this now I can take c5
immediately or I can take d6 and go
Queen f3 both would win a pawn but my
development is really not good really
not
you know not really not happy here
I'd like I like positions with better
development but okay
yeah I'd have issues here with my bishop
yeah g2 is hanging that is really
annoying annoying fact soon and I'm king
of true I see no other way to get this
get this developed
look g4 and then maybe I can put some
more pressure on the apron I think I'm
okay really it just looks a little bit
odd one thing in my favor is that this
Bishop on g6 is really not doing much
really not doing much at all okay see
what is he doing them trying to double
on b7
[Music]
interesting now is it taking and deform
but I thought this is good
which might be a wrong assumption but
it's not easy okay so this is a way for
him to get back into this VM I can take
here with the Queen cannot take with the
rook on before and Queen takes a three
is definitely better for what Queen
takes me to I'm in a three
now so I have to convert this position
now this is owned objectively speaking
winning for white just have to you have
to be precise them okay go ahead do I go
who could be won or how do we how do we
handle this
I need to get rid of the Queen down and
be to a vibe if possible I can also try
to go form go for the rook it goes back
we will probably try to play some f5 as
for paunch eggs no it's fine
and this is fine for what the D 3 point
is just not so strong and on the other
hand c6 is basically doomed
he cannot at the same time I think
support the deep horn and cover the c6
porn
okay so kinky three I don't have enough
time now shoot to figure out if I'm
winning this if not it's just a shame
but I've got those dangerous pawns and
now the c-pawn should do the trick or
the beep
and that is terrible I had such a shame
how can you not win this freaking game
it's just a shame it's just completely
over and I'm spoiling it again I'm just
pointing so many winning positions it's
just terrible sorry I mean he can play
such just not on yeah playing so badly
and winning
you just have to refute this it's really
awful
I know maybe he's not able to win this
yeah it looks like it that's very odd
yeah but I mean come on come on just
it's just friggin that cannot be
it's just winning this position how did
I manage to spoilage this stuff so yeah
actually made it of course I saw this
move but I simply felt ok I don't have
to look at this yeah but I should I mean
it just winds yeah of obviously and I
thought this this should win as well but
yeah and it does win of course I am such
an idiot
so we'll see 6 wins yeah see six cannot
take it yeah that is that is too quick
so we'll see six and this then I've got
b5 yeah so you just have to just a
little bit of precision it should be
seven is just awful and now I'm spoiling
it to a loss even you know instead of it
is drawing with king D - yeah and then
somehow it was not a win but that was
also quite odd yeah yeah black should
just win you don't think anything is
wrong up to this point the engine so
claims it's Owen and now now we are
dealing with the repetition so how does
black win then so King f8 and ke8 okay
so King aid would be distant opposition
so kingi v king e7 Kingi forward King f6
we actors perform King D for king of
seven that doesn't win so let's figure
this out so how does that when actually
so let's say King e5 King is 7 now
irritating me this this is this thing
gives to draw the whole time let's just
go back there so king deform
if I've never wins that's clear he has
to play the king and basically any King
move seems to win that is irritating to
me that actually table base we had a
stable base so they all win young king
e7 kingi v king of seven that's clear
and then here in this position I played
King before and they they they all win
did I find amazing probably you can
always get the same position but the the
the thing that that does win what is did
a distance to zeroing okay I really
after okay
King create so King me five King e7
if I had the same thing so and now you
have to go King d6 and it's kind of
clear actually how you get here while
you get you get this yeah and then
you're managed to make progress
so once here what black needs to do is
he needs to to get the King if I
kingi seven position so if you go here
you have to go to d8 so that this can be
answered with King is seven kingi for
you go to d7 so again that this can be
answered with this and then he gets him
so that is the whole thing he has to
basically when we when we're starting
this he needs to go here to win and he
needs to do it in this way so that after
king e5 there's always king e7 so that's
the way to win this King and pawn ending
okay yeah but I should just win this of
course anyway okay guys thanks for
watching and I got the wrong number here
that is blitz chess number five four
seven six five thanks a lot for watching